[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  the government should have handed over  everything in good order instead of  running away like it did i have a  money in a bank like uh  4  4 000  but  but i can't cash my money from bank  people's access to banks and to cash  remains a real problem the banks have  largely remained closed when they are  open there are strict limits on how much  you can withdraw and it all points to a  much bigger fiscal problem of how  afghanistan is going to pay its way  under a taliban government  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  because the banks are closed and  people's mind is stuck in the banks  there is no business if the banks are  open then people come  [Music]  [Music]